They say a rose is a symbol of true love.
And here's a cheesy little trick that might
help you find it.
For this project, all you're gonna need
is a single serviette. Open it flat on a table,
then fold one of the edges back about an inch
and a half from the top. Now simply flip it
over, and place one of your thumbs on the
corner behind the strip. We're gonna roll
the whole thing, around the outside of our
thumb, until it forms a tube. And when it
looks like this, try pinching it off just
below the flap, and gently twist, until it
starts tightening up. This is gonna be
the flower's head. Let's keep twisting it
down another inch or two to form a stem, then
take one of the corners at the bottom, and
fold it up along the side. You should be able
to see how this corner, is forming a little
leaf. As we continue twisting the stem down
the rest of the way, it should be starting
to resemble a real flower. But the flower
head doesn't look very convincing yet. To
fix that, let's reach inside and twist the
inner folds around, and now it looks incredible.
The flap on the outside can be gently pulled
up around the rose head to make a little decorative
hood, and it's done. You've just made an instant
white rose, to impress somebody special. Now
check this out. If you try spraying a little
perfume or cologne on the flower head, it
will smell good too. I gave one of these to
the girl of my dreams 7 years ago, and now
we're married, and have 3 kids. If you don't
have a special someone, try using it as a
fancy way to tip that cute server that just
brought you your food.
Well now you can turn a humble eating accessory,
into a clever expression, of your affection.
By the way, you don't even have to have a
napkin. I just made this one with a hamburger
wrapper. How awesome is that? Well that's
it for now. If you liked this project, perhaps
you'll like some of my others. Check them
out at www.thekingofrandom.com